hey youtubers is charlie thank you
everyone that submitted questions for
this week's Walking Dead QA everyone
really excited to push further deep into
the comics but you know I feel like
there were a lot of polarizing opinions
just because not a whole lot happened in
the episode everybody let me know if you
didn't like the episode last night and
whether or not you're a comic book
reader sometimes it's a little easier to
swallow episodes like this if you have
an idea of what's coming down the road
even if they change things a little bit
there's still some really exciting stuff
that's coming let's get to some
questions though so just careful for
spoilers from the episode if you haven't
seen it yet so here we go Josh asks when
negan shows up in a future season or
something do you want The Walking Dead
to be a higher rating since he says
f-bombs a lot so you're talking about
like the TV rating everybody always asks
Robert Kirkman about negan at comic
conventions usually he talks about the
stuff that they're not going to do like
dramatically change the character so I
think they'll be as true 2 f-bombs as
they can be on basic cable you have to
remember they're not a network show so
they can get away with a lot more than a
show unlike NBC or ABC or CBS good so
don't worry too much about them taking
the piss out of the character I think
it'll be okay next question Sergio asks
was I the only one that thought the
attack on the barn was a dream no I
think they wanted you to think that
because remember they had the argument
about whether or not this was real life
you can think of the show thematically
as a really bad dream this
post-apocalyptic world all the bad
things that have happened to them
Michonne is hoping that they'll wake up
from that Rick disagrees he's acting
like his grandpa did in that story
they're walking around an enemy
territory so to him it's not a dream but
it's also not necessarily home next
question moogle berries as one thing
that's still bothering me about the
episode is the focus on Maggie's wedding
rings they came up so often I couldn't
help but be suspicious yeah I wonder if
they're just messing with us a little
bit in the writers room just wanting us
to think that someone's gonna lose a
hand especially because of that picture
that Norman Reed has posted we have
Abraham's hand we have maggie's hand
Abraham just got cut with Sasha's knife
Tyrese got his arm chopped off before he
died it'd be really awesome if they
continue to do that for the rest of the
season they just kept playing with us I
don't think that writers do that to be
malicious like they're not trying to
make you hate them for teasing you with
some comic book moment I'm not expecting
it to be one of the main characters just
because if they're going to be on the
show every week that's a lot of
prosthetics there's just a lot of work
to go through
Robert Kirkman said it's all fair game
though so that doesn't mean that they
could change their minds in season six
season seven so someone could totally
lose an eye someone could totally lose
an arm next question Chloe asked do you
think that the new character is a threat
to the group well I don't think he's
like a physical threat I think he's just
a threat to their way of life I think
he's more dangerous to them because of
what he represents or what they perceive
that he represents remember the stranger
danger stuff whenever he stepped into
frame I think that's what's going to be
on everyone's minds for the next couple
of weeks and I don't expect Rick to ever
trust them if anybody's gonna drink that
kool-aid first I think it'd be Eugene he
was the first one to pick up the water
bottle he did he didn't care if there
was poison in it or not next question
Tony asked do you think the tensions
will boil between Sasha and Michonne
seems like they were about to go into it
at the bridge fight no I think that
Michonne is just trying to bring her
back from the edge of sanity both Maggie
and Sasha were going off the deep end I
think the end of the episode when they
started to smile watching the sunrise
they started to come around a little
they started to come back to sanity
maybe not a hundred percent but I think
their quote unquote out of the woods
that doesn't mean it's going to be
smiles and hugs from here on out but it
does mean that sasha is probably gonna
stop lashing out at everyone next
question chaos device asks so you had a
really long comment it was really
awesome but I'm just going to focus on
that last part where the hell is Morgan
so that's really interesting because if
you remember Aaron knew who Rick was he
knew his full name that means that
someone who knows the group is probably
at the Alexandria safe zone cue the
drumroll hopefully that's Morgan there
aren't that many people that know where
works group is and where they're headed
that would be willing to help them out
Morgan saw the map knew they were going
to Washington DC so maybe he beat them
there and then told the people there
about them next question generico asks
what about the random dogs was it an
easter egg for something to come there's
a couple possibilities it they could
just be feral dogs running around in the
wild or they could belong to a new
mystery group that we haven't met yet or
they could also have been sent there by
Aaron when I say sent there I mean he
could have directed them into their path
he left them water so it's possible that
he also directed some food into their
path next question mr. maressa s why did
Abraham knock the ball out of Eugene's
hand when he tried to taste it well I
think that it was just a reflex they
thought that there might be poison in it
Abraham kind of scene
like he's in survival mode right now so
he's just gonna do the first thing that
comes into his head I still think
there's some tension between them but
but I think the group has realized that
Eugene does have things to offer them he
is a smart person next question Tiffany
asks do you think that the lightning
storm taking down the walkers was a sign
from God well I think it was just part
of the religious theme in the episode
you have like you know Rick with his
Noah's Ark beard and then you have the
Biblical Flood the show isn't super
religious or anything like that they
just want to leave room for that
interpretation I think they're just
counterbalancing the idea that just as
much as is there's a chance of something
really atrocious happening like their
friends dying there's also a chance of a
miracle happening it also kind of help
that they saw the Bible sitting there in
that shed next question Lucas asks is
Alexandria the arc that nicon appears in
actually there's a couple of things that
they can do before nagin comes
alexandria safe zone is a big place in
the comics but there are a lot of other
things that they can tell that are part
of the comics I think they will stretch
it out a little bit if you have read the
comics and you want to talk about some
of those other things that happen
between Megan and Alexandria safe zone
just please use spoiler tags thank you
everyone there's so many questions for
this these are always a ton of fun to do
yet I mean the episode very polarizing
it's kind of weird when they go from
really crazy to really quiet stuff but I
think if you stick along for the ride
you'll be happy with where the show is
going congratulations to this week's
giveaway winner sci-fi attic you in a
twenty-dollar amazon gift card just be
sure to message me on the back end of my
channel so I get your communication info
next week's episode I think is going to
answer a lot of questions about what's
going on with Aaron and what his
intentions are and in how close to the
comics they're going to stick so be sure
to subscribe to get that video i'll post
it after the episode airs my Gotham
videos going to be posting next if
you're not watching that show you should
totally check it out there doing a joker
storyline I think it's going to be a lot
of fun so what you guys wait for all
that stuff to drop you can click here
for my walking dead episode 10 video and
you can click here for my latest Game of
Thrones Season 5 video thank you so much
for watching so let's all high five I'll
see you guys tomorrow
you